all right guys
bang bang a very special guest today my
friend jonathan is here
uh how are you i'm doing great
all right i want to start uh with your
childhood and growing up
because you have a very unique
experience that i think
feeds into a lot of your world view but
before we do that
i'm going to tell a story that i don't
know if you remember this or not we
worked at facebook together
uh you were the last boss that i had at
facebook before i left
and there was a meeting um the details
don't necessarily matter as much
but uh we were all in a meeting with
some of the higher ups at facebook
and there were some suggestions floating
around as to things that we could do
on facebook to get more people to pay
attention to the executives at facebook
one of the ideas was to put an
interstitial over uh
the uh the page and a lot of people at
facebook were like oh that's a great
idea like
you know we can basically like that's
how we get people's attention and it was
very much like a data-driven
okay there's gonna be a certain number
of people who see this
that click that then you know opt into
this action whatever
all normal conversations for kind of a
silicon valley firm
and all of a sudden not only halfway
through the meeting you're like
uh excuse me so i'm not from the united
states
and let me explain to you what used to
happen in television he's like
the dictator of our country would come
on and be like
now interrupting this programming and
like this is the thing and your point
wasn't so much like
the social media ceos or dictators is
more of just like hey there's multiple
cultures that use
uh these platforms like we have to be
sensitive to the way that this could be
uh received
and i always think about that because i
think you probably better than anybody i
know
understand silicon valley you've built
companies sold companies worked at many
of these tech companies et cetera
but you also very much understand like
the world outside the united states and
have been able to like mesh that
together
people got really angry in that meeting
if you remember it was very tense i do
remember that and
i left and one of those very important
executives in that meeting and i
remember
some of the guys from the team you know
kind of
higher up in the hierarchy than me
saying i've never
seen seen this guy this angry ever
10 years of a company ever i was like
holy crap
yeah i can remember that yeah
i do remember them getting mad i was
gonna leave that part out but yeah yeah
they got really
tense you know there was a very tense
meeting yeah well i think that there's
uh
there's always some uh hint of truth and
everything right of just like yeah like
that might not have been a good idea and
thankfully we didn't do it
yeah okay um that's a tough job you have
there i remember
you had a tough kind of an intersection
of a lot of things that facebook had to
do
i was very i was very unprepared for
that i was a 25
26 year old kid and um i was
asked to basically interface with these
people on a
pretty periodic basis but also then to
interact with other executives and
you know it's like a minnow getting
thrown in with the sharks and you're
like oh
okay yeah and i think i think what
happens one of the reasons that job is
hard
is because if you if you're before that
you were doing that if you were starting
companies or
just generally hustling you have an
output mentality
you're like how the how do i get stuff
out how they're gonna podcast out and
your product out and you feature out
and you're outcome oriented in a large
company
you have to be input oriented you have
to go like so what do you want bp of x
what do you want b b of y and you're
like well if i phrase it
like so are we all in agreement and can
we take that to the higher ups and
and you were i remember in a role that
had a lot of that
it was very painful that was very
painful i
i think i always to this day say uh
it was nine it was uh no three months
give or take in this specific role
yes and uh i got into the role because
basically some of the executives were
like
hey we think that this guy would be good
at this because he had done some other
stuff
yeah they went to uh my boss's boss at
the time i remember
hey can we talk to him about doing this
and they were like no like we're still
going to talk to him yes
so it wasn't much choice yeah did it it
was awesome
you know gotta interface with all these
people really good people
had amazing people i learned more than
i've ever learned yeah 90 day period i
learned
i still to this day believe i learned
more in that role than anything else
but i was very unprepared for that right
yeah it was brutal it was
good to work with they were they were
they were hardcore good
talented you know to this day i will
still
i think that this is probably true
there's nobody better
than that team in terms of uh and we're
talking about some of the earliest
facebook employees that have
you know risen up through the ranks and
still are in charge today uh
the combination of product
analytics growth like like everything
together yeah
you could give them any problem in
technology and they got a shot they're
amazing very resilient
really hard working there's good people
but yes all right you're not there
anymore
yeah it's fine well we're okay we're
both out i learned that's fine but there
was many walk-in talks that we did yeah
i was like hey listen all right so
here's the deal and we took a remember
consensus yeah i was learning as well
with you to be honest i don't know what
i was doing yeah
you grew up in venezuela which uh i
think
uh with some of the background knowledge
of being able to say that in that
meeting okay like hey
yeah let's maybe cool it a little bit
here uh what was that like
it's interesting i grew up middle class
in in venezuela and
that's actually very comfortable to some
degree you know like my
both my parents worked at uh kind of
state-owned companies
that worked at the oil state comp
estate-owned company you know
it was a top 10 company by market cap
for a while
my mom worked at the uh kind of the
alcoa like the
you know steel state-owned company
it was a good comfortable life but it's
also a
in a very an equal society and a very
unstable
society um you know i got mugged
growing up several times my mom got
mocked
growing up several times gonna get out
of the car and the car goes
uh my dad got mugged several times and i
would negotiate with guys like take
take the shoes don't take the watch or
whatever just like don't
don't leave me hanging but my brother
got what's called
express kidnap you know like for a
couple of hours well they they grab you
coming out of like um have you been
coming out of it isn't even where we
lived it was like
coming out of i don't know mountain view
in california like a really nice
neighborhood
at 8 00 p.m on a tuesday from like
imagine cvs
and they're like we're getting in your
car
and he was kidnapped for a couple of
hours and my brother
my brother was very effective persuading
them that we have no money
i don't know what you're gonna take and
my brother remembers distinctively the
thing that shocked him the most
is that by all material accounts
those guys were better off than him your
car is better your shoes are better your
jeans are better your what your glasses
everything you guys are the cool kids
i should and he's like let's take my
debit card and just take whatever it
won't it won't be much they're very
disappointed
um i got mocked by police once growing
up
growing up i was in a red light and they
got in the car and they're like drive
and and and i remember my mom used to
own a small
shop where she sold um after she left
the state company she sold
lottery tickets and i had the money for
the price and i'm like you cannot touch
that
that's my mom's and that's someone
else's you know these guys are police
they're like yeah we won we won't take
that and they
they were so angry at me because i had i
remember 20 bolivares which is like
nothing in my wallet and they're like i
can't believe that's enough and we get
we
we ran out so it was a lot of crime and
a lot of insecurity
um at least there's honor among the
thieves there is oh
they can be very kind and then uh and
then um
there was a lot of political turmoil um
and then kind of financial turmoil
right um you know when i grew when i was
born
the balance the exchange rate was for
4.3 so 4.3 bolivares
for one us dollar okay my time i was
like eight or nine i can recall but i
could remember this
it was 16. so forex basically right
by the time i left college it was a
thousand
right now so i kind of lost track here
but i think i want to say that because
they debase the currency twice
and change names with this canon and
basically
when you're talking about debates not
just like printed more like literally
they took zeros off the end of the
currency
but that's right you rename it so like
it was a million bolivia or whatever
it all says a thousand right and so and
where did the zeros go and they had this
kind of over we were talking before
about over having overconfidence and
like the perils of overcome confidence
right
these guys will call that the base
bolivar they are fuerte the strong
believer
stronger has less heroes right right
so i want to say that on the liver that
i grew up on
the week the week one the weak one
this guy um
right now i think the exchange rate
would be 3 billion
wait what three billion i think it's
thirty thousand
but then three billion on you know yeah
so they're weak on the weak one yeah yes
so before they took all the zeros off it
literally went from
four to three billion well it never
really
showed the ticket three billion because
it was debased yeah yeah yeah yeah
but but yes if you if you anchor on that
volume
if you anchor on that believer and go
all the way to today it's three billion
so there's a lot of change to give
people who just to like hammer the point
home
if you wanted to buy one dollar as a kid
you needed four of the local currency
that's right and you would get one
dollar in exchange you could go right
hey here's four give me one
now you'd have to show up with three
billion that's right and so and they
literally would be like you'd be like
how do i carry that
that's right that's right that's right
and and and now
in this happens in venezuela i haven't
been there in a while what happens in
venezuela you can see this in colombia
as well in the frontier and the border
uh even the newer bolivares which also
have been debased and kind of weakened a
ton
they're used for um um like art yeah
arts and crafts yeah so they'll be like
they'll do like a purse made out of the
bolivia so they'll make a little plane
or they're worthless right
growing up in that environment do people
know
like do they realize it or is it just
like oh that's how it is everywhere
that's a good question i'm not sure to
what extent things are being realized i
i do think
people realize inflation is kind of it
can be seen
and i remember having conversations as a
kid and in the streets where you know
because
you see inflation's in inflation in two
ways right one way
is things get more expensive the other
way is that products get uh refactor
to maintain the price would be less
less quantity less quality whatever it
may be so i remember
as chocolate that we liked growing up
that kind of kept the price for a long
time
it just got tiny right from this to this
so it you know and people know right and
they know it doesn't cut out
the price is the same what you get is
different right so you can also do that
right uh a lot
that happened a ton right and we kept
getting you know you know the backs of
chips with like
less and less the loaf of bread just
becomes one slice right
and so all of that keeps happening so
people are aware people are aware of the
kind of purchasing power
that's something very real what i don't
think people realize
fully is that um is how inflation is an
indirect tax
on the poor that's a piece that i'm not
sure is visible because what happens is
that if you live in a country that is
highly
inflationary and you're able to
save in a strong currency
for local expenditures inflation is
actually
beneficiary in the sense that you know
if it's like
if the if if the if the things get
debased but your your savings get
stronger
you can come back and then buy more and
so your your
your you know purchasing power and your
quality of life doesn't get that
affected
if you're saving in the local currency
because you can't take money out or you
have a lot of expenses
then it's a pretty clear tax and i'm not
sure people
follow that i think the other thing that
happens is that inflation is an amazing
indirect tax
for governments because they can divert
responsibility so they can say look at
the chocolate factory
they're making the chocolate smaller
that's not right
or look at the coffee shop the coffee
now is 10 times more expensive
that's not okay you're exploiting people
and so it's very easy to like divert
responsibility for the indirect tax
and so it's very very popular for uh
governments right it's very useful to
them
you're talking about venezuela you could
be talking about the united states
yeah i mean in terms of inflation
affecting the poor in terms of the
diverse
the diversion of blame in terms of the
arguments of exploitation
uh minimum weight i mean all of this
stuff
is the exact same in the two countries
maybe on a different level of
severity right but systematically
it's the same thing that's right i think
the other lesson that that you get from
the us
that it's less apparent in a place like
venezuela
but i think it's very important is that
when you and this kind of
graphs are very popular circulating
around the internet right when you see
the lines of inflation you're like well
car
you know flights have gone really cheap
or cars are getting really cheap but
look at education
or look at healthcare and and then if
you look at those
costs and you look at who's impacting
them you can see how
regressive that tax the inflation is
like
who's actually paying that bill and it's
not being paid equally
it's being paid very unequally and the
poor suffer more
right because those are the things that
they spend more money as a percentage of
income
health care is a smaller uh expense than
than it is for someone who's poor and so
if that goes up you disproportionately
hit the poor
the poor population there's a study that
um
i will try to find again i'll put in the
showdown for everyone uh
that looked i think it was in uh the uk
so not the united states but uh
in an english-speaking kind of developed
nation um
and it looked at after the 2008
financial crisis
they basically broke down the
socio-economic kind of ladder into 20
buckets so top 20 next 20 all the way
down right and what it said was
uh by their estimation coming out of the
2008 financial crisis the bottom
40 percent of uh people in their country
uh were experiencing somewhere between
six to ten percent
inflation levels so when you think about
that the official numbers
to maybe two and a half percent
it's kind of a blend across society
ten percent every year
things are going i mean you just can't
keep up right it's that feeling of
everything going up
but i always go back to like the system
is doing exactly what it's designed to
do
they want to devalue the currency so
people spend or invest and
keep velocity of money going it's just
only that like half the population knows
that and acts accordingly right they buy
ass as they do all this
everyone else is just trying to do their
job and eat right i mean there's no
uh understanding of economics there's no
understanding how money works there's no
understanding of what i should do to
protect my wealth or grow my wealth or
any
it's 45 of americans don't even own a
single investable asset
and so it's actually the education gap
seems to be what
exposes people more than anything
because the system's doing what they
designed it to do
right that's the scary part that's right
and if you look at this is true on a
place like venezuela like in the us the
more so
there imagine you're in venezuela and
imagine you have
uh excess income that can be turned into
savings of
75 how do you turn the equivalent in
bolivares to 75
what's the financial system that
provides that
to that saving how do you do that
without being charged
25 in the transaction or whatever that
might be same
here right i mean it's part of the
problem is that it is hard through the
financial system
and even to to to save you know to save
lower amounts over long periods of time
it's expensive
and and the system is geared towards
debt way more than savings and so
there's great products to leverage up
there are not that many great products
gonna save up there's new stuff in a lot
of the
most kind of cool interesting stuff in
fintech it's trying to solve for that
uh but it's education plus
infrastructure
when you think about a theme in the
world you've written about before like
the dissipation of power like this whole
idea that
uh maybe the last i don't know 50 years
or so there was the concentration of
power how do we create more efficiency
seed in politics venezuela is like the
perfect example there's many other
countries where
uh consolidation of power leads to bad
things apple's absolute power corrupts
absolutely all that
but you'll see it in corporations right
and i think one of these pieces that you
wrote was
this whole idea that um when you have a
hundred
small two-person companies you have to
negotiate contracts you have
to become uh transactionally efficient
and all stuff
it actually just makes sense like why
don't we just put all the 100 different
companies of two people
into a 200 person organization and we'll
create top-down hierarchy and now all of
a sudden
we don't need to negotiate every time we
need to do a transaction like it's just
internal
and so we can create efficiencies and
get this but it's centralized
it feels like the world is rejecting
this a little bit or trying to head
in a different direction with this
dissipation of power like how do you
look at that
today yeah so i think the one thing that
i would say
that is interesting to consider uh for
people who
are kind of strong advocates of the
centralization and diffusion of power
and so forth is kind of what you're
saying that
senatorization is really valuable like
it has a bunch of things
you were referring to a pretty famous
book in kind of a
microeconomic literature called the
theory of the firm and so this guy goes
through like the logic for why firms are
created and companies are created which
is kind of what you when you
walk us through and that that's i think
exactly so so it makes sense to do that
right
um let's just walk that argument four
steps ahead and just see
see how it plays out and why that
becomes an issue well that now is
concentrated right
so now maybe they are underserving a
subsection of the market and so you and
i get together like well we're going to
fight the big company we're going to
serve this kind of small niche um
it turns out the company controls kind
of distribution channels turns out
the company can kind of underbid uh
products or over bid on products to kind
of get us get us out of the of the
marketplace
and so so so now it's hard to compete
and and hard to serve this kind of
subset of the market that needs
serving and so now regulation is issued
and ensued and so
laws get get get put together to help us
um kind of fight uh but what turns out
is that
uh laws are hard to follow and so more
laws are built to protect the court law
maybe you maybe you got a constitution
but then you're like well we got to
protect that so we're going to put some
laws
and then you're like well you want to
protect those as well and you put more
and this is
i mean this is a history of kind of
liturgical practices in religions as
well right like i'm jewish
and it starts simple and we get a ton
right and
and this idea in judaism exists of like
defense of the law
which is our laws to protect us all
and this happens on like the civil
society as well and so you
you bring in government to protect the
little guys so they compete with a big
guy who became
big for arguably good reasons but then
perhaps
not so much after a while and then the
loss in itself they become big and the
guys who
issue the laws can are nested so now
you're like at that point where you're
describing when you're like oh
the the system is becoming exclutic it's
like not moving right
and so you know the guys at the santa fe
institute has this idea called like the
edge of chaos
and they're like you know we live in
this kind of in this kind of
edge where you know people go bankrupt
and people die
and we suffer and yet this is where
still things happen if it's too
uh too rigid and too static and too
concentrated and centralized
stuff doesn't happen change doesn't
happen improvement doesn't happen if
it's too kind of gassy
you know and kind of disperse no
coordination is possible it becomes
really really hard
so there's like some place where you
want to be and so and so to your point
um you know the us in the last 30 years
has been you know the single power
in the world that's really unusual right
just like you know history-wise
um and i think it's pretty patently
obvious to everyone right now that
china is a real contender
and and and you look at that in
corporations to your point you see like
strong
concentration of power on subsections of
society and commerce and so forth
and so sometimes you have to work to
kind of concentrate more power because
it's kind of too diffuse and sometimes
you have to work to kind of
defuse it to defuse power and i think a
lot of what i think
i think world cup called for call colon
to work on is to diffuse some of this
and i think you can work on a bunch of
different verticals but there's some
there's too much concentration and not
enough change and innovation
and kind of improvement and we have to
we have to diffuse i think
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business
and a very happy user i think you will
be too when you go to
blockfy.com pomp again blockfy.com
go check it out and let me know what you
think all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
it almost feels like uh moderation is
good
right yeah too much decentralization and
maybe that doesn't work
too much centralization and maybe that
doesn't work and there's this like happy
medium
uh but it's not just okay everything is
halfway
centralized decentralized it's it's more
so
there's certain things where
decentralization is really really
important and then there's certain
things where centralization is really
really important
and society is trying to figure that out
right yes
i can imagine you know i can imagine if
you think of yourself in different times
of history
being kind of consistent in values and
principles
and at some point yelling you know break
the kingdom you know everyone on their
own you know
and some more time of history saying
let's bring the kingdoms together
and let's consolidate and you i think
you probably are remaining
uh principled you know uh by doing
things that seem very opposite
i do feel that we're at a point where a
lot of like let's break the kingdoms
feels important to me right yeah i tend
to agree yeah
yeah bitcoin is
interesting because um it's doing some
of this
yeah very unique way uh still an untold
story or kind of an unfinished story but
we'll see what happens you are should be
like a poster boy
for having sympathy for what bitcoin's
trying to accomplish
come from venezuela hyperinflation
there's concentration of political power
you've seen um kind of this play out
through your lifetime across many
different verticals
how do you think about the asset itself
and i'm cheating because i know you
think it's important but just like like
what is the framework you use to
evaluate it given that you could use so
many different frameworks
yeah um well i'll say this perhaps
on some historical context and so i
remember the first time i heard about it
was
by a colleague which actually was
actually x facebook and joined my
startup before we joined facebook
and um you know like a bright strong
libertarian
and it was like this thing is the future
and i remember thinking you know the
typical concerns around kind of
government regulation and
you know and the laws that provide
coinage and all this type of stuff and
getting really concerned
but you know i also remember i remember
growing up in venezuela
one of my professors is a guy called
leopoldo lopez who's become
an important member of the opposition
he's now in spain and
went through hell on earth on some other
government's
prisons and i remember in a class that i
had with him he was like
the importance of an independent um
fed or the equivalent of the importance
of an independent fact and a lot of the
kind of traditional economics
and have have argued for this have
argued for like
the fed should um aim to control
inflation to have an inflation target
which should be independent of the
fiscal policy
so one thing is how much money we're
going to spend as a government to
achieve the government goals
and that should remain independent of
the fed goal which should be to manage
inflation
um that's really hard
for it to happen right independent the
independence
but it's important that we we recognize
that
we need predictable monetary policy to
for the agents to
to to act in the best interest of
themselves and the economy
if the monetary policy is unpredictable
then
it's very hard to plan inventories
uh it's very hard to control import
exports it is very hard to price things
um and so i think this from a practical
standpoint before
a lot of the kind of cyberpunk uh
libertarian philosophy that gets
uh on behind bitcoin that may become
possible i think the idea of like
same predictable monetary policies i
think is a non-controversial
position among many economists basically
what you're arguing is if you take
widely accepted kind of consensus view
traditional
economic viewpoints like
predictability uh like independence of
the fed or central bank or whatever
and you apply it to the lens of bitcoin
there's checks that gets you 30 there
yeah i guess you're a third there maybe
yeah
monetary policy is transparent
programmatic programmatic and
predictability are just two different
words that mean you know pretty much the
same thing yeah
programmable is just like the uh a
strong incarnation of predictability
right yes that's highly predictable
independent yeah decentralized those are
again you know
two different words for two different
industries but basically you know uh
rely on each other or are kind of
related to each other that's right
and then if that gets you 30 what's the
rest yeah so i think the
the the second the the rest is that
you realize how hard it is to accomplish
that
and you realize that the monetary policy
of a nation
is really powerful that it can be used
as a diplomatic tool in other nations
that it can
be used as a domestic policy tool uh
to you know gen to pass a bunch of money
to a bunch of people or whatever that
might be
in a way that is not organic organic so
that one piece is he realized that
there's a bunch of incentives in that
system that go against that um
ideal and that push against it that's
one piece
and the other piece uh that is important
is that
and i and i i grew up and to a large
degree i remain
kind of very kind of liberal kind of
almost to the left in many issues
but i think one thing that hayek and
kind of the father of kind of
libertarian economics has
right is that price convey information
right a price is the way we discover
truth in the market
and so if if you tinker with prices
because of
foreign or domestic policy objectives
and
you're not just you know indirectly
taxing the wrong people
you're not making it on also hard you
actually
screwed up the market mechanism and i've
seen
i i've seen in practice efforts to super
the market mechanism for like a top-down
mechanism and it
does not work it's really really really
bad this is
uh this is not only the history of
russia but you can just see it whatever
this happens it's just top down it's
it's just pretty hard
and so so i think those those that is
like the other third which is like
prices are really really important and
the incentive structure is against it
and i think that all kind of checks i
think the last piece
is the piece that you realize that
this thing is
not cannot be censored cannot be
controlled so it means that
no one can grab power over it and so
going back to the other point
is that when you look at this
concentration of power what bitcoin has
is it has the property of diffusion of
power
no one has to be in control and that's a
notion that's very scary and very
um it's not clear if that's going to
work or not i mean we've tried full
concentration
of power that doesn't quite work well we
tried kind of market
plus governments and it works better but
it has a bunch of issues
but this idea that we can effectively
take something that we want it to be
predictable
and that we force it to be predictable
and it cannot be controlled by anyone
else
it's insane so i think once you see that
and you see that that's possible it's
really a different world and
and you see examples of all of that i
mean i there's a bunch of news uh
on the news right now on kind of
miners being the platform and kind of
china in china
i don't see anyone coordinating the
migration of those machines
somewhere else and yet it's happening
it's happening
they're being migrated and you know the
hash power has dropped dramatically is
the network
threatened or unsecured and so i think
the magic here is that we've come up
with a way of
effectively diffuse power without
becoming chaotic but the opposite
there's no concentration of power and we
get
full predictability i think when you see
all of that you're like well
to your point it still has to play out
but you're like this is a worthy
experiment if nothing else
it almost feels like when you strip away
sentiment
right and you kind of say shut twitter
off stop looking at the us dollar
exchange
price shut the television off like just
look at the actual
stop refreshing the app yeah like all
these things right just like like time
out for a second
yeah and you just look at it from a pure
structure standpoint
it's got to be one of the most
beautifully designed
kind of valuable things at that
viewpoint
of technology in a long time like maybe
the internet right is probably like the
other big one where you're like okay
like there's kind of like this
distributed system
where people all kind of work together
information can flow back and forth and
um yeah there's some centralization here
or there that actually makes it work
and whatever but when you look at this
you're like i can't really think of that
many other things that
if this becomes what it has to promise
to become
will be more important right and value
has kind of all kinds of
you know subjective type things that you
can apply like
is it priced in bolivia or dollars but
just it's almost like it was perfectly
designed
and and the word perfect i think is
scary because nothing's really perfect
but it does check a lot of these boxes
and so it's maybe
the best that we've seen so far out of
all the monetary policy well
i think so i would agree i think it's a
thing of beauty
right from like a technological
standpoint from a societal standpoint so
it's it's amazing
um but i think you i think in in i think
you're right also in the kind of
description of making think thinking
it's perfect
in insofar as it's very narrow
like it does one thing doesn't doesn't
do more
and it's here's a clear meaning
transparent
predictable a permissionless
not censorable monetary policy which is
what i think there's some people who
don't agree with this and some guys in
the new york times will go and write
about the importance of like active
monetary policy and
i would tend to disagree but i think
there's a bunch of guys who are
far from the crypto punk libertarian
world that would say we need predictable
monetary policy we need bands
in which we can operate some flexibility
maybe but
just some some somewhat predictable um
and and this bitcoin achieves this
specific goal so
to that sense it's just very well
tailored for a very specific thing and
so
maybe we'll find something better but i
think part of it what makes it amazing
is that
it's not actually trying to do too much
it's just really important
how important is it that we just saw
kind of the exact opposite over the last
12
you know 18 months or whatever with uh
basically completely unpredictable
uh monetary policy emergency interest
rate cuts
uh trillions of dollars of quantitative
easing like
it almost feels like we basically over
the last decade or so have seen
bitcoin gain adoption slowly but surely
and
kind of chugging along technology
continued to work
individuals were really kind of
attracted to it then you started to get
a couple of financial institutions that
were uh this is interesting
and then covet hits you get literally
just mass chaos complete uncertainty
uh the most extreme version of
the usage of a malleable kind of
unpredictable monetary policy
and then oh there's this other thing
like just keeps doing what it does and
so now it's like this black and white
comparison of
hey here's the extreme of one world and
then here's like the other extreme
essentially
yeah and it seems like that really
opened a lot of people's eyes so like oh
maybe i can't even describe why but like
this is interesting because this other
thing is
chaos yeah well that's i think i think
there's one side of the argument that i
would
that that's against that or in front of
that which is that i think
uh the maybe the bitcoin community tends
to um
i think understate the power of the u.s
dollar
the united states is an insanely
powerful country
uh it has uh insanely strong economy so
i think kind of the u.s
the token whatever you government token
i think it's
it'll stay here for a very very long
time i think the us has
um advantages that china doesn't have
it's an open country that accepts
immigration that takes talent
that speaks a language that people can
learn chinese is hard to learn
i think we have some disadvantages kind
of military-wise we have like a long old
platform that needs to be upgraded uh to
find more wars and so forth but u.s is
very powerful so
i think they so so what that means is
that like companies
that can make uh a string of mistakes
and that they're still there because
kind of the core business is so powerful
and you see that in technology all the
time
the u.s can kind of screw up many things
from now to the immediate future and
remain i believe
particularly as it pertains the strength
of the us dollar
but uh i i do think
that when you look at um like if you
when you look at what the dollar can buy
and when you look at kind of the
purchasing power particularly
domestically right
um i think i think you i think you're
right i think people are seeing maybe
this is not the store of value that i
thought it was maybe it's been kind of
compromising i think as i said i think
it's a larger theme where
the us was the only country the us was
the only dollar
that lasted about 30 years that's gone
uh
i don't see the euro being particularly
strength in that regard as i said the
chinese currency is tied up with a bunch
of like closeness in the chinese economy
so
so i think people are looking for like
stable predictable strong value and i
think they can
can fill that that role that's in the
u.s if you're outside of the us if
you're in salvador if you're in
venezuela
then then the because the u.s dollar is
used
as a kind of diplomat diplomatic kind of
non-violent intervention
tool uh then i think diversification out
of that
kind of may prove to be important for
them and then the question is like going
back to the u.s
how how again what's what will remain
for a very long time and hopefully
forever like a strong
economy and an open society that takes
on thailand and so forth
uh how does that connect with like this
store of value i mean the us
has gold in hornox and they're proud of
it i don't i don't see them complaining
about it even though it has been kind of
made illegal in a bunch of transactions
in the u.s
um i don't see why the u.s cannot be
open about this in the future but i
think it's not
i do think it opens their eyes but i
think i think the us dollar
will be okay talk more about el salvador
and kind of when you heard that news
uh just given that south and central
america i think you understand to some
degree just
having grown up um and then bitcoin and
technology i think you understand pretty
well as well and so you put those
two things together most people are
evaluating this from the
the american perspective right i look at
i'm like oh this is amazing they're
gonna go give bitcoin to everybody
how do you think of it is it a dangerous
thing is it a positive thing is it like
a wait and see
and like there's action that needs to be
behind the words or like just like
what how do you evaluate something like
that i'm not sure to be honest because i
think part of the challenge for me
is that um
[Music]
i don't know how to judge the actions of
a president
that has a bunch of power and control of
congress
and when they do something around this i
think it's not positive for society
um but i i i don't have an argument
against any of this
uh like a well thought of argument um
but i i i hope that
bitcoin gets in the hands of as many
people as possible before
you know governments start to get
involved just because i think the power
of what it can be will be stronger
the more kind of distributed and the
more in the hands of more people
and so i kind of get a little bit
nervous
uh but but i do think that um if i want
to be optimistic i think the idea of a
government
uh thinking through the future and how
they can participate in it and how can
they kind of
do leap frogging i think it's important
so i'll give you an example
um in many developing nations
there there never was a kind of a
phone infrastructure the way they had in
the u.s or europe cellular phones
effectively
leave frog pad into into where it is
today that was important
it was important to invest in those
towers and not invest in kind of cables
under the ground
because it allowed those economies to
like
get the iphone and get android and get
apps and and and kind of really move
forward
and so i i do some of these financial
institutions and services and kind of
economy in these economies are are old
and inefficient
and expensive and unfair and so
what's what's interesting for me is that
if if the financial
kind of systems of these countries can
kind of leapfrog by adopting this
technology
i think that's really really important
that's one so i think lightning becomes
really interesting
part of that story for me and so that's
one i think the other piece is that i
think
um i i think it's important if these
countries can get early in a store of
value that has some space for
appreciation if that then if that's what
happens
then i'll be excited for them to see
take a little bit of risk that it's not
kind of
country threatening in any in any
important way but they have the ability
to take risks that maybe the us doesn't
have and that they can benefit from that
that would be exciting exciting for me
as well yeah
it feels like um
most of the folks that i've talked to
from uh south and central america
there's just like cautious optimism
right hey i see how this could be
beneficial if it works out right
uh any country in that entire region
uh there's always this uh belief that um
you continue to rise in power and then
when you get the power it's kind of like
what do you do with it
right and probably more so maybe the
african continent
but more so than anywhere else in the
world south and central america has seen
the
negative sides of what can happen with
consolidated power
and it feels like when something like
this occurs
there's an argument of like oh this
could be used in a negative way
right and we'll see kind of if that's
true or not
but also then there's this argument of
like the trojan horse like it doesn't
matter if you're a good guy or a bad guy
if you go and you help all of your
citizens get bitcoin you can't control
it
right and so like to some degree uh
there's a diffusion of power yeah right
just because you're literally using a
freedom technology and you're giving it
to everyone yeah
um but this brings us back to this piece
that you wrote
of kind of this diffusion of power where
you talk about the idea of like there's
basically three reasons why
somebody ascends to power and it's they
think that they can organize resources
in society better
uh there's a self-affirmation or they
basically benefit from the perks
of being powerful and in it
you essentially lay out and i forget who
this argument comes from but it's like
if you don't do the things that everyday
people do very quickly you almost lose
touch with the everyday people
right and so i think the examples that
are used are like you know
if you don't make your own coffee if you
don't you know uh drive your own car
like all this stuff
yeah for no other reason than just you
don't do it
it's kind of hard to relate to people
who do that on a daily basis right
the thing the thing to realize at this
for me is yeah there's this famous lore
acton
you know power corrupts and absolute
power corrupts absolutely kind of quote
i think that's very true and i think i
think it's very important to stay
vigilant i think that's where i've i've
moved to in that journey
to some extent where i'm like i'm just
generally suspicious of power
and generally suspicious and and
generally kind of feel
a sense of kind of compassion to some
degree with people who hold a lot of
power
you see people who hold a lot of power
in big corporations technology and
otherwise
always in impossible situations right
like almost you almost they don't want
the power and you see
for example um jack dorsey at a twitter
advocating for this blue sky project
that effectively
and and you see it you know takes power
out of him and you see him on the uh
on the interviews that has or whatever
the subpoenas that has been uh
asked to to attend to in congress
effectively saying
should we have i mean sure should you
have that much power should i have that
much power
and i think before that meant chaos
and i think now that means kind of at
the edge of chaos
it's kind of crazy but but it works kind
of the machines the mining machines will
go where they need to go the bitcoins
will go they need to go the exchanges
will do what they have to do
the notes will do what they have to do
the individuals will be sovereign and
they'll make their own calls
so so i think there's something to that
right where
yeah we're probably probably the problem
is power and we now have a kind of
anti-power or delusion of power uh the
illusion of power kind of technology
that it's that's now available
jack is so fascinating because i'm
pretty sure he
explicitly says uh around all the d
platforming
shutting accounts all stuff he's like i
don't want
to be the one doing this right or or
like we we like we basically we
this is not something we signed up for
yeah right we have to do the best we can
to do what we can in the meantime but
the blue sky thing is kind of
like how do we give the power you know
elsewhere
what's fascinating to me is uh for every
one person like that
there's a hundred that they want the
power yeah right and then they're
actively working to get the power and so
it really um it begs the question like
will it take technologists
building the technology to diffuse power
regardless of what the
incumbents think or do we get to some
point where people start to say
ah you know maybe i don't need the power
like like it feels to me that
jack kind of raising his hand and saying
you know we have to find a better way
without us being the ones making these
decisions
that's going to be a very unique you
know kind of path
most of the times it's going to just be
more of technology taking the power
regardless of what the income is like
we'll see i think i think it's like
if i have to guess it's like think about
jack in a meeting
in a content moderation meeting like i i
can't imagine anyone enjoying that
meeting
right do you imagine that being
pleasurable i don't know if mark
from facebook is doing this or you know
susan and youtube
i i i don't imagine this being fun i
imagine it's being
really really painful um and everyone
knowing it's impossible
it's an impossible task yeah and it's
unclear why it's been
for all the [ __ ] that these guys are
getting i mean i'm on the side of
facebook on all of this it's like why
are they being asked to do this
like i think that modern civils like a
modern society
would have like um api interface
between the courts and facebook
and i would go and say i think this is
harassment and then we have
uh we have we have content court we have
we have
we have laws for this we have amendments
for this we have the civil right
we have we have laws that we have
decided in a democratic environment
that decide if that is harassment or not
and if it's punishable by law or not
and so i will click and then some guy in
court
it will be a computer go like okay now
now we'll go to
court and they'll be we'll see we'll see
your day in court and they'll be judged
and we'll decide
i'm not sure why this is the hands of
this guy jonathan why did you tweet this
right okay how did you feel when you got
it i mean if it's worth if it's worth
discussing it it needs to be
solved by a third party then we have
course for this and then maybe we need
to hire more people in court
and we have a and then content
moderation shouldn't happen in a
deloitte factory in in pakistan i mean
maybe it should happen in in our local
courts like my point is that
i don't think they want this the
government doesn't want to take it
everyone wants to point fingers which is
the point that i'm making then maybe
they should
have a project to develop an api
interface into between the courts and
all these guys
i don't think the government wants to do
that i don't think they want to staff
that up i don't think they're capable of
doing it i don't think they want to deal
with the consequences
and so i think mark and jack and all
these guys rightfully so are saying
i think it's you you need to tell us i
wasn't democratically elected
right i mean yeah what are the rules and
then we can apply
i can decide to kick someone out on my
own terms but if you're asking me to
kick someone and you're complaining that
i didn't do it then
then maybe you should you know maybe
maybe maybe maybe it's on you
do you work do you worry do you worry
that when we get into that world
um there is uh the nation state
or the court system now choosing who
gets silenced who doesn't
it's in well i think i think that's
right i think it's impossible
i think the nation's that's just as bad
as asking mark or jack i think the
nation state model is
it's not compatible with this you know
i think i almost imagine the world like
the medieval times but
but we have like the amazon kingdom and
we have the facebook in them and it
spans across you know geographies and so
so i don't think the nation state is
like the right tuning for this i think
jack is right in saying maybe
maybe maybe something like blue sky
maybe maybe no one owns it
yeah maybe you kind of choose your own
adventure maybe you choose your own
adventure
and it's on you and i think we just
trust people
to make the right decisions and again
maybe there are courts and courts can't
but this is not so centralized
so so i don't know i think going back to
the initial point
i would imagine i don't know him and you
know i don't
i wouldn't presume that i know him by
tweets but
i would imagine he doesn't like going to
content moderation meetings i would
imagine that's a pain
and i would imagine he recognized
congress
asking questions about bets they made
among each other and like showing
at times complete ignorance of
technology which is scary
as he is a steward of that company that
he says
now we have a technology where a way of
not concentrating power in this way
um so i don't think people like power
even the ones who have it
at the end and it also brings up like is
it so much that power gets eliminated
or the power basically gets given to
something that can't
abuse the power right so bitcoin being
kind of the quintessential example of
like
if you take the power from those that
have it today and you
uh make bitcoin more valuable and that
becomes the global store value let's say
you didn't really destroy power right
what you did was you just
shifted it but you shifted it to an
inanimate object that basically is
programmatic it's transparent it's
somewhat democratic and in terms of
things could change if everyone
agrees or a large majority of people
agree
but it's still powerful right i i think
the way to think about it is and
and i think people sometimes i think
having a weak vector of attack to
bitcoin is when people say oh you told
me bitcoin is gonna
you know make some sort of like
egalitarian financial world
but see the rich keep getting richer or
the richer or continue to get richer of
course i mean if you have money and you
convert it and you buy the right asset
and appreciate so bitcoin is not going
to make the poor
rich magically in some or none of these
technologies
but i do think it eliminates power in
the sense that again very narrowly
like if you are the chairman of the fed
in the u.s
and you are taking a bunch of
considerations to decide
what you're going to do with your
monetary policy with the interest rates
and some of them are in the benefit of
some people some of them are in the
benefits of some other people
today or intergenerationally may be good
for us and horrible for our kids
to the extent that bitcoin becomes like
a true store of value the way the u.s
it is in some cases in some cases in the
kind of balance sheets of central banks
in other nations
that's gone that's gone
it's the monetary policy for bitcoin is
predictable
and non-changeable and so that little
piece of power i mean not fully as i
said i believe the u.s dollar will
continue to be very strong but you've
taken some of that out so
and who has that power really we gave
the power to an algorithm
so the algorithm is really powerful
right now and so when you think about
that
it's this weird world where you're
basically giving power like i always go
back to just like
uh the robot overlords are here and we
love them yeah right
and you know you let the algorithms do
everything from tell you what content to
consume
what direction to drive down the streets
right
to what search results uh to where to
eat
to what happens with the monetary policy
i find that argument to be completely
kind of non-threatening to me i mean i i
think we are
made to be bionic from the get-go
but we also have okay extension but what
i mean by that is that
we came up with tools very quickly at
some point we start
we stopped you know you know scraping
the earth with our nails and we invented
a shovel
and without the shovel a bunch of stuff
would have been impossible so it is an
inorganic extension of our body for all
sins and purposes
right and you could not function without
the clothing and the heating and
the cameras and these are like true in
organic extension in our body so i mean
bionic in the sense that i don't think
we're fully
um our our biological matter i think we
are all these things that we
you know steve jobs has this kind of
beautiful like called computer is the
bicycle of the mind
it it really is like your bind works
differently and gets wired differently
and
moves faster and two different places
through the technology so i
so i'm i don't see why it's a bad thing
to depend on the cell phone to give me
the weather and i don't see why it's a
bad thing if we agreed
as we said before or not everyone agrees
because many of us agrees that monetary
policy should be independence from
fiscal policy
and predictable that we make it so by
using computers i i don't find that
threatening at all
i don't think it's a bad thing yeah what
i think is fascinating is
as we do more and more of this across
our life do we basically take power from
humans and continue to give to
algorithms
it's actually probably a pretty good
thing like imagine um
somebody recently told me that uh
they're they have a father who's older i
don't know how old he is
uh and he still looks at uh mapquest
before he goes on a trip yeah and he
tries to memorize all the turns yeah and
they're they get in the car with them
like hey
is that better you can use the gps right
yeah he's like no no
like i got it yeah and so
pretty you know uncontroversial to say
like no using the gps would be better
but as we do that more and more people
just have to get comfortable with the
fact that like the algorithms have the
power but if they're decentralized and
no one controls them because i think
that's the problem right now
is when you think of like big tech right
like let's take the argument that uh
against the technology companies
yeah it's not so much that the
technology has
power it's that somebody controls the
technology
so if facebook was completely
decentralized and nobody controlled it
how many people would really be mad at
facebook yeah i think a much much
less amount of people are mad because
it's useful that
mark is a human and has a face and you
can point at it
bad guy yeah it's very easy right and
very unfair also i think and i think
that when you
take that out of the equation like in a
situation of bitcoin
there's nobody to point to i think
that's true i think the other piece so
related to the pointing which is right
there's no one to point to but i think
the other reason is that
it it affects i think what follows from
that i guess is the it
it appends our model for
responsibilities and liabilities so
here's an example that i used to hear
before that i think it's interesting you
know algorithms are getting more into
healthcare
right and if you think that from like a
machine vision standpoint
reading a two-dimensional black and
white image
is not you know it's not harder than
having a car drive itself
just to put it that way right and and so
so you tell
people and you're like well the best
human
a radiologist or whatever it is
analyzing the image will make you know
10 mistakes 90 percent accurate and then
let's assume the machine
is like 97 percent accurate three
percent will make
so machine is better than humans right
if the human makes a mistake
who's responsible the human it's very
simple and there's we have legal code
that supports like many ways to manage
this and
ethical conduct and moral rules and so
forth to deal with this
he'll say sorry it will be a bunch of
stuff that will happen right
an emotional sec and so forth or gas
lightness but yeah yeah
yeah now there's the algorithm make a
mistake who's responsible
i have even not having who to blame is
problematic
from like an emotional standpoint now is
it the creator of the algorithms to
blame
who will he lose a medical practice like
will he be judged for my practice
it's very hard from like our models to
figure out who to adjudicate uh
responsibility now
unlike google maps which you can imagine
google being a nefarious actor
re-routing you
from what it seems to be you know a low
traffic kind of
green path outside of the highway to
kidnap you and take your car
they don't seem to be motivated uh they
don't seem to care too much about you
and me right to go and do that but you
could imagine that
the same way you could imagine that for
healthcare
bitcoin is pretty dumb from a
computational standpoint
it's not gonna reassess and you know
it'll just i mean
you could not predict potentially like
the hashing power but it's
being used at some point but it's like a
one you know one derivation from
the kind of core algorithm that kind of
it's mining at a certain rate on certain
blocks on certain time
and that's not so it's actually actually
almost dumb
meaning i find the monetary policy of
bitcoin to be
way less threatening imagine being a
macroeconomist or a macro hedge fund
manager
and you're waiting for mr powell whoever
is a fat guy
have you seen these guys reading these
the conference room or the conferences
yeah yeah have you seen the
like the it's what would thai what color
thai did he say the word dovish or not
it's it's hysterical it's astrology for
grown men
it's it's it's sad it's astrology for
grown man that's exactly right so you're
going to tell me
that that's more reassuring than a dumb
algorithm that i told you in advance
what's going to do
and it's telling you predicted it was
going to do on something where you want
something extremely predictable so i
would argue that i mean the machines are
coming
it has a bunch of implications that are
serious and we should be concerned about
them
i think people should look at google
maps and see what we how much we trust
them and
and how insignificant we are each of us
to google like they don't
gain anything you know doing anything to
us
they appreciate us opening the app but
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
right
uh please click on our ads but but to
the extent where algorithms can become
kind of
making this more important decisions for
us to you're right the fact that it's
not controlled that it's open that it's
inspectable
that's your thing you can see the code
for bigger you can see it running
and the fact it's not controlled by
anyone it's actually pretty powerful
you're right
you could also argue that go back to the
algorithm that is
analyzing the 2d image and with a 3
error rate
if it was open source it probably would
be improved over time uh 100
right just you just get more and more
eyes on it right 100 and then all of a
sudden you put a couple of million
of dollars as the reward right right and
i think
the point is that it
it has a path to learning and improving
that may be close to a human
i mean you look at all the stuff that
has happened with deep mind and the go
games the puzzling thing is the path
that they take to win and that's kind of
partly how they win because the guy
looks at anger like i don't
i don't know what strategy you're
following but they found this kind of
you see this also on
i don't know if this company called 3d
metal it's also venezuelan guy by the
way
and you see that they they kind of
programmatically build
pieces that have to you know perform a
function
in a machine and they end up looking
kind of
alien they're not what you would imagine
the the algorithm finds a path of like
optimal weight
and and cost and whatnot that's not what
you expected
so i find that amazing right they'll
find solutions that we're not finding
it it's um i think people have jumped
all the conclusions
maybe it was facebook where they had
like two algorithms supposedly like
talking to each other or something
they're like shut this down
like terminator style like yeah
microsoft had an issue with this like
bob that went nuts on twitter yeah
and when you kind of see it you're just
like look uh sure
there's risks here whatever yeah but
most of this
is pretty simple and i think your point
about like
get rid of all the noise just focus what
exactly this is it's a predictable
monetary policy and that's pretty
powerful on its own
it doesn't need to have all the bells
and whistles and this is this what
no it's just this is what it does yeah
and i think in the case it's like
what's sophisticated about bitcoin is
not the monetary policy it's actually
very simple what's sophisticated is your
is the protections that have put in
place so it's
permissionless that it cannot be
censored and is very hard to attack
that's what makes it amazing actually
the actual monetary policy is
what we all want very simple very very
simple
yeah before i let you go cause i know
we'll run out of time here um
when you think back over your career in
technology
what's like the one or two biggest
lessons that you've taken away that you
think people in the bitcoin crypto kind
of decentralization world
could uh benefit from are there specific
lessons whether it's around
you know building teams building certain
types of technology uh
servicing user bases like what do you
think are like one or two really big
lessons that you're like you know what
if i'm at one of these companies right
now i'm building one of these projects
here's two things that i think is like
pretty applicable across the board
let me see very simple question yeah yes
yeah i think one aspect that i feel more
confident saying is that i think when
new technologies come
i think a broad mistake in kind of
technology businesses
is that we tend to try and fill market
holes we see the market and we're like
why don't we have a uber for dogs
right so and that type of game uh
you know dog walkers are important it
has the same type of supply and demand
etc
and that type of kind of thought process
kind of very kind of
system-wide to an application sometimes
yield good results for sure but often
you just yield um unproductive things
because that type of thinking often is
the opposite of what like
you know pj and yc guys would say which
build things people want and so
sometimes
that market hold is there for a good
reason no one cares
right and so particularly when the new
technology comes
you know we started learning we started
learning to do things with like deep
learning and some kind of machine
learning stuff a bunch of applications
built around that are built because it
can be built
not necessarily because people kind of
want any of this and what happens with
crypto to some degree
is that it allows for a lot of things to
be built that were not possible to be
built in the past and
and i i don't know if that's avoidable
in any meaningful way
but certainly i think a good reflection
is to think over
am i just tinkering with the technology
because i think it's cool
and because i see the system and i find
a hole and i think a plug
goes there or do i actually have some
sort of validation for the man and to
understand where the money is coming
from and to understand the customer
needs and
that type of stuff i think that's i
think that's one and the other problem
which i think it's kind of
i think there's many camps around this
but i think one of the problems that
i've seen particularly with crypto
is things over financed right
um you know
a lot of money is very problematic you
and i have talked about this before is
the idea that uh
you can starve a company or a product by
not having enough money
but you can also uh kind of drown it
suffocate them
right right literally give them so much
money that all of a sudden they don't
worry
about money yeah and very quickly they
spend it all yeah sometimes you have to
stop taking money
even if it's being offered to you and
that's very hard it's very important
and i think that's true because again
people who would argue against this
point would say
money is not always available you should
take it while you can
there's some truth to that i think the
counter argument which i'm trying to
present
is that uh and this is true of
corporations and of individuals is that
when you have more money than you know
what to do with it
you tend to start making silly decisions
uh
you start not seeing trade-offs
trade-offs get obfuscated by money
and so you throw money out of it in the
hopes that the trade-off would kind of
go away but the trade-off is like in the
metal
of the consumer experience of the
product so you have to go fix for that
and i just throw money at it
um or you may kind of grow too quickly
and kind of get the wrong user base
and then there's like the practical
implication that if you're a shareholder
or like a token holder and have an
equity holder on of an asset that has
been
you know vastly overpriced then you know
it's like a highway
where you just start taking exit exit
exits out of the highway right
and you're like well now i have to get
the tank to make it all the way from
miami to west palm beach because i took
all the exits out
and that seems sometimes you know
there's some value in burning the
bridges for sure
but um but i think it's i think you i
think you calculate
you're like okay it's very far but but i
know the jump that i'm making i know
what it's going to take and you know
what i mean
so it almost feels like uh rationality
is uh the holy grail right
it's if you can rationally assess what
if people actually want
probably going to build something
valuable you can rationally think
through
undervalue or under funded versus over
funded right you kind of find that
moderation and say hey this is what we
need
right if you can kind of think through
all these things it really just boils
down to it i think one of the things
that you do so well is just like the
clear thinking
right and kind of the rational thought
ends up being an advantage when the
world is so irrational or people
around you are so irrational i think
also i think it's an issue of like
sticking to first
principles right which is what let's
allows you to say as we were saying
before
you know divide the kingdom in one
epoch and then like 200 years later say
you know
unite the kingdom and you're being
principled and that you haven't really
changed them
and then the same thing happens i think
you can be widely risk-taking and bold
in kind of your vision and the product
making and what the technology needs to
do or the thing you're trying to achieve
in crypto or otherwise
and then be widely conservative on the
management of your funds
until you know what to do with them and
i think you have to be able to like and
it's and it's not
i don't think that's in conflict and i
think it's a certain perspective
which is the one that i would warn
against that make you think those things
are in conflict and you're like well if
i'm super bold and i'll take all the
money
then i'm like well maybe not maybe yes
at some times yes i mean if you're
uber and you're competing on the ground
and maybe you do that
but even then maybe you overextend
yourself maybe you shouldn't have come
to aisha asha you should have stayed
here maybe yes maybe not
you know who knows and they own a bunch
of db and maybe that's a brilliant idea
but my point is that sometimes the op
the correct thing may be to take all the
money in the world
often it's not and i think in crypto
just because how things are
may be problematic yeah i tend to think
that you're right
there you go where can we send people to
find you on the internet or
read more stuff you write um what's your
twitter account oh my tutor account yes
okay jay geller so that's
j-g-h-e-l-l-e-r all right and then when
you write
i i start a little blog gather that co
so g h e l l e r that co
all right you're not gonna say it so i
will it's very very good
uh heavily heavily uh i've tweeted a
couple of times
you have a few of them you bring a lot
of people because i actually find them
valuable
uh so i highly suggest go to geller
g-h-e-l-l-e-r dot co
and they can read it there yeah all
right and then follow him on twitter
oh my god thank you for doing it yeah
that's fun i will do it again in the
future yeah let's